I've seen the help that you've provided
to men right I mean men watching you
guys and seeing and learning from you
but as long as the ladies don't learn
from you the problem still
exist my that's why we do the Ladies
Night Show yes so and again with that in
mind right you've been doing your ladies
shows uh Mike and Rolo have been going
their way pressing fit but I haven't
really seen any of the girls actually
learning anything out of it the only
girl that I've actually the only female
that I've seen changing from something
is J daa after they talk with Rolo but
that's basically it how can we get the
ladies to actually learn from this how
can we get them to actually understand
this so yeah that's an interesting
question um it happens but it only
happens when they get older it it only
happens when they're forced to accept
the facts of reality that I talk about
so um 90% of my viewers are guys and
then the other 10% are women obviously
um about half the women hate my guts and
the other half don't they actually like
my [__] every single chick that digs my
content is older they're
all maybe 30 on the low end 3540 like
3540 plus right and it's because they're
forced to accept the realization that
what I am speaking is actually true
because they reflect back and upon you
know their past choices in the life that
they've made and they looked at the
results they looked at their belief
system they've looked at the choices
that they' make and they start to go huh
maybe this bald bearded handsome dude
actually knows what the [__] he's
talking about so I don't think you're
ever going to convince these young
bimbos you know that you see on on some
of these podcasts sitting around tables
um that they should contemplate some of
these ideas because they just don't it's
like you might as well argue with a
stapler it's G to get you just as far
and that's exactly and that's exactly my
point I know exactly what you're talking
about they will come to their censes
when in 28 30 when they're hitting the
wall when they want to settle down but
by then they already run through they
already lost all this capital on
themselves they've lost all this right
so then men have to either settle with a
run through hoe or a boss bit or
whatever yeah how can we I don't
understand you are all very smart guys
right you Rollo everyone right in the
sphere how can we not just come together
and find a way to convince them young
that this is a wrong way of doing it
they don't want to listen man they don't
want to hear it they've they've been fed
a steady sequence of Lies their entire
life and every woman today that you're
dealing with now has had a cell phone
probably since they were about six seven
or eight years old and as soon as they
started getting social media and using
uh social media apps more specifically
that are by the way scops that are
programmed to uh soften and weaken the
Western maale and turn them into soft
weak betas and to turn women into
disagreeable boss [__] um it's it's
been happening forever like I I am not
optimistic about the future of you know
men and women I don't see things getting
much better like I see Pockets where
guys
are applying this I see some Pockets
where women start to apply it there are
some younger women like uh I'll be
honest with you if you watch some of the
ladies nights there was one in the last
month where there was
a she was Malaysian or Thai I can't
remember but she was living in Australia
and her job was professional girlfriend
if her boyfriend uh had a golf
tournament on a Saturday morning at uh
5:30 a.m. she would get up at 4:00 to
make him breakfast and tidy up before he
left um there are women out there and
and she's in her 20s and she's
conventionally feminine and attractive
objectively most guys would say anyway
um so they are out there um it's
just sorry those are definitely the
exceptions not the rule they are but
again I mean like this is a woman like
when I was talking to her um you know I
was asking her about her childhood and
her parents and what her father's you
know beliefs happen to be and and she
said something great interesting you
know she said my dad who you know she
said has a very strong accent because
they're culturally from that country um
would say a woman's job is to serve her
man and a man's job is to serve his
customer and that's the simplest most
convenient uh traditional way to distill
the gender roles and she got that you
know from that from that family
upbringing and from that culture so it's
not that it's not out there with any
young women it's just more rare than is
common and I think that the only time
that most of these bad boss [__] um
in their 20s and even early 30s come to
the realization is when they're forced
to when they realize that they struggle
to compete with the younger more
attractive women because they're now
older right um not all of them get there
but a lot of them do a lot more of them
do now anyway I definitely agree with
you on this one then you said that
you're not optimistic I'm actually
terrified from the future so what what
I'm I'm because I'm the sort of person
I'm always proactive right I'm I'm 27
years old my net worth is almost
$200,000 now aiming to be a millionaire
by the age of 35 so the thing is I I can
see it happening and I'm thinking how
can we all come together and prevent
that from happening prevent males use
sex dolls to go off and women being in a
relationship with one man 10 of them
with one man and then we have have a war
out there how can we prevent this right
is it our message that it doesn't go
through how can you know what a lot of
guys SOS will come to the question like
how do we fix this like what is the
solution like how do we remedy this
issue and I don't think that's something
that I want to do it's it's not worth my
time I'm not here to save the world I'm
here to enjoy myself draw a perimeter
around myself and the people that I care
about and I'll kick up my feet and drink
a beer smoke a joint whatever and watch
them burn it down I don't give a [__]
don't [__] care um there's there's
way too much wokeness there's way too
much of the nonsense out there
progressiveness inclusivity the world
hates straight white males you know
today it's like I don't [__] care I
don't care I just don't care my job is
to tell the truth and help guys and any
gals that want to you know come along
for the ride too understand these
raw uh inconveniences for a lot of
people that must be understood and
followed if you want to get better
results out of life uh I'm not here to
convince people I don't give a [__] I
really don't it's like if you don't like
my stuff it's fine yeah and that's
actually something that really
disappoints me I mean look at you right
you're Prime alpha male back in back in
time you would be a king right having a
king say that I don't care about my
subjects they're not my subjects not a
kingdom to yeah not subjects they don't
pay me taxes they're not in my Army I
don't give a [__] I mean that's the
thing right wouldn't I mean again it's
all hypothetical but if if you could put
your brain to it I bet you can
definitely find a way to actually so
save us from what's come right I get it
and I've and I've had this conversation
dozens and dozens and dozens of times
but I don't give a [__] I literally give
so few [__] I have no [__] to give at
all when it comes to saving other
people's [__] at all I just don't I
just
don't it was nice talking with you rich
I hope everyone out there how to think
about it and let's all push together we
might make you give a [__] and then we
are
safe look man I'll let you go um look
man I've I've written a book that solves
many problems again if you haven't got
it get it it's cheap it's on Amazon that
solves a lot of problems if you guys
want me to solve The World's problems
the best thing that you can do is solve
your own problems
because if you solve your own problem as
a man and become the best optimized
version of yourself okay I'm not saying
compare yourself to Richard Branson or
the next Hollywood star that you might
follow but if on a scale of 1 to 10
you're rating yourself a six or a seven
on your scale you got work to do don't
worry about the rest of the world don't
worry about the hose don't worry about
the weak men don't worry about the
government don't worry about any of that
[__] optimize yourself until you're a 10
now that you've done that draw a
perimeter around the people that you
give a [__] about and take care of them
because you'll be more than busy taking
care of the people that you love and
care about within that perimeter because
that's us and then on the outside of
that perimeter that you draw that's them
and I don't give a [__] about them and
what they do because they're going to do
what they do anyway they vote for stupid
government policies they vote for
policies that uh force me to pay 65% of
my income in taxes I don't give a [__]
I'm not I'm I'm not going to go out
there and take a microphone or a speaker
phone or go on the street you know and
be that King that I could have been you
know 2,000 3,000 years ago or whatever
the hell he's talking about I don't care
these people most people want to carry
on with their life drunk on the Kool-Aid
of [__] that Society sells them
sleepwalking through life getting basic
ass results and wondering why their life
sucks sucks I don't give a [__] let them
stay fat incompetent you know slow I
don't care they don't want to be the
best version of themselves that's
fine I've got thousands of videos out
there I've got thousands of podcast
hours I've probably got close to a
thousand interviews on other people's
podcasts where I I spread the message I
can't do anything more than that I don't
give a [__] beyond
[Music]
that going to come off my uh pedestal
for a minute there but look man I get it
you know like you guys want me to save
the world for you save yourself you
won't be asking me to fix the world if
you're already a 10 on your own scale
you won't because you won't give a [__]
either you'll get to the point that I
got to because you only have time to
give a [__] about the people within your
perimeter that's it I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe here and pin down below in
the top comment you'll find a bunch of
useful links to my website my supplement
line books and a bunch of other stuff
have an amazing day peace out